[Musik]
freundlich denen nicht man schon mal so
ein bisschen
wir machen heute sport mit bibi ich habe
letztens schon mal auf einen kanal
reagiert auf dem baby anscheinend vor
babys beauty pelle schon videos
hochgeladen hat in diesem video zeige
ich euch wie ihr eure augen groß finden
könnt doch dort wurde die zahlreichen
die kommentare geschrieben
luca baby hat noch einen zweiten kanal
gehabt und zwar heißt dieser kanal
fitness welt.tv werden dann
beispielsweise so videos hochgeladen
wie unter anderem flachen bauch
trainieren fitness übungen für zuhause
oder hüftspeck weg trainieren abnehmen
tipps oder übungen für das knie fitness
übungen oder oberschenkel innen
trainieren oberschenkelmuskeln
oberschenkelmuskeln und ich sehe hier
gar nicht mehr lange um den heißen brei
herumreden freunde wir sagen jetzt an
wird beim board mit bibi danke das
brauche ich
wie soll ich mich denn hier jetzt auf
den boden legen ich mache die übung
jetzt einfach mal sitzen also das ist
dann auch meine kappe verabschiedet sich
gerade
doch mal kurz ja auch die kamera
anpassen also ich sitze jetzt hier
ehrlich jetzt gerade so halb auf dem
boden also baby wacht jetzt vor
okay das wirklich nach vorne
ja da spüre ich schon richtig mein bauch
nice wie bibi nach der übung einfach
noch so komische die kamera guckt ja
[Musik]
nicht nur drauf den ganzen oberkörper
links rechts okay das heißt dass man
jetzt wieder nach
hier also die bereiche hätten die
arbeiter die den sonst so wie wir das
richtig anstrengend ja hier haben wir
stets hoch und jetzt die pflanzen beide
hoch dass unser boden auf dem boden
bleibt das nächste video das uns baby
freundlicherweise auf ihrem kanal
fitness welche form zur verfügung
gestellt hat ist dass sie hier ihren
hüftspeck weg trainiert
ok ja ach du heilige scheiße jetzt muss
ich als auch joggen gehen oder was okay
okay das sieht überhaupt nicht auf ich
gerade aus 15 x ich habe ja
wahrscheinlich auch den ganzen tag zeit
[Musik]
ich habe wirklich richtig erlebt wie
mein hüftspeck sich einfach in luft
aufgelöst
das ist ja echt relativ krass gewesen
ist mit der übung wie mal schauen was
jetzt noch folgt ok ja ja ok ja auf die
brust seitlicher setups
ja und jetzt zur anderen seite also das
mache ich jetzt auch mal freunde das ist
das entspannteste video wirklich dass
ich jedem einer komplizin karriere
aufgenommen habe ich bin ich unendlich
dankbar dass sie mir diesen kanal in die
kommentare geschrieben habe was würde
man hüftspeck jetzt ohne baby tun beine
anwinkeln die rechte seite
[Musik]
das haben wir doch vorhin schon gemacht
die nächsten übungen die uns wieder
gezeigt sind für das knie also wir sehen
hier schon ihre wunderschönen beinchen
ich denke da jetzt einfach mal direkt
auf play hallo ich habe keine knie also
ich halt wieder ab als unterlage du
liegst du auf deinen zwei teppichen das
müssen wir langsam ganz toller
ausstrahlung also dass linken beides an
gewinnen können das rechte bein locker
und jetzt kommt locker laster komplett
durchschnitt lassen jetzt wieder
komplett durch
jetzt nahmen es locker das ist einfach
langweilig also ich weiß echt nicht was
ich ohne diese videos machen würde
wahrscheinlich weiterhin fordert
verpacken
ich schlafe ein bei den videos
[Musik]
ich muss noch mal ganz ehrlich gesagt zu
geben freunde aber ich finde es cool das
baby früher solche videos gemacht hat
muss ich wirklich sagen weil dadurch
haben sich eventuell recht viele leute
das hüftspeck weg trainiert real tag
also das soll überhaupt nicht gegen baby
gehen wie ich finde deinen letzten
videos sogar recht eigentlich ganz neues
video hochgeladen hast deswegen würde
ich sagen trainieren wir jetzt auch
zusammen mit dir die oberschenkel von
innen
ok naja ok diese standen übungen als das
bein so hoch heben dann wieder und
wieder müssen hochheben damit darunter
dass ich ein bisschen hochleben
das sind jetzt die oberschenkel ist denn
ihr allerdings für euren seitlichen
brüssel
gold für die stabilisation könnt ihr
euch halt auch einfach nur hinlegen und
das mal so halten ich meine sie zwar
nicht so aus aber ich bin selber drei
vier mal die woche im gym abends und
macht er halt auch meinen trainingsplan
mit seinem trainer und deswegen also ihr
könnt mich schon glauben oder halt auch
nicht aber bei was sie mir auf jeden
fall glauben könnte ist das der beste
merchandise shops als nächste übung
zeigt uns wie man den bauchumfang
verringern das heißt wir kriegen auch
hier einfach mal auf play ja dass das
klasse ein wenig habe kann ich habe
basketball ja
[Musik]
also quasi einfach setups die macht hier
also einfach sit ups auf einem
gymnastikball und das was ist das glaube
ich einfach ein kissen oder so also
fährst du quasi einfach nur ganz langsam
fahrrad
also danke auch auf jeden fall für die
übungen bbm dann haben wir als letztes
video seitliche bauchmuskeltraining ich
auch einfach mal direkt auf play geil da
freue ich mich genau das super teppiche
sind immer klasse
[Musik]
das ist gut das baby das erkannt hat
dass das wirklich 45 grad sind
und jetzt macht ihr eine seitliche einen
seitlichen heute einfach ok also meine
hände auf den schultern
jetzt zum linken oberschenkel genau zum
rechten die wir machen auch mal direkt
wieder nach keine ist angewinkelt am
ende auf den schultern einmal hierhin
genau dann wieder zurück
hierhin ist schon ist schon anstrengend
aber freunde ich bin ja nicht hier auf
dem kanal von fitness welt.tv babys
trotz trainerin wenn es nicht
anstrengend sein dürfte ok wieder an
kraft
nur mit dem oberkörper
ok linke arm ja ich ganz immens haben
keinen bock die übung jetzt auch noch
mal nach zu machen
das war es jetzt hier vom video meine
damen und herren ich habe heute einfach
mal mit der bi ein bisschen mein bauch
trainiert mein knie trainiert meinen
bauchfett verringert wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann lass ganz ganz gerne
mal einen like da freunde und schreibt
mir doch mal die kommentare ob ihr auch
sport macht wenn ja cool wenn nein auch
cool
jeder sollte machen was er will das was
ihr vom video das was jetzt hier vom
video ihr könnt jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten mal einen
schock aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ich ein abonnent
seid könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken
dann willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]